Today we're going to talk about sorting.
And in particular, we're going to talk
about two very well-known sorting methods.
One is called Selection Sort; the
other one is called Insertion Sort. And
when people learn about sorting methods
they usually learn about these as being
two completely different ideas. You have
selection sort on the one hand and insertion
sort on the other hand. And what I'm going
to show you today is that these are
actually the same; you can regard them as
being equal. The trick is that you just
draw pictures of them. You don't need any
coding to see this; you don't need to
know any fancy stuff. In fact, you don't
need to know anything about computer
science at all. If you just draw a
picture of selection sort in the right
way, and a picture of insertion sort in
the right way, you see that they're
actually the same thing. And this is kind
of a secret about sorting methods that
even people like me, who have been doing
computer science for many years - most
people - or hardly anybody - actually
knows this little trick. We'll start off
by kind of refreshing ourselves with
pictures about what sorting actually is.
So, let me draw a box. What we're going to
do is put some numbers into this box.  It
doesn't matter how many numbers - everything
which I'm going to show you is completely
general - but we'll do it with five.
So suppose we do a 5 and a 2 and a 3 and a 1
and a 4. These are the first five numbers, in
some kind of random order here. But the key
thing is they're not sorted, they're not in
ascending order. What we'd like
our sorting box to do is
give us the same numbers out, but in
sorted order. So we'd like to have 1,
2, 3, 4 and 5 coming out.  Let's
start to think about how we might
construct a little program which
implemented this kind of sorting
procedure here. The most basic building
block which you can think of is just a
little box with four sides. What this box
is going to do is on the left-hand side
and on the top side you're going to have
two numbers come in. And then, at the
bottom, the smallest number is going to
pop out. And on the right-hand side the
largest number is going to pop out. So
you can think of this as being like
little sorting box for only two numbers.
So, for example, if we put the number 1
in on the left-hand side and the number
2 in on the top, then what our little
sorting box would do is give us
the smallest one out the bottom
and it will give us the biggest one out
the right-hand side. So, this is a sorting
box for two numbers. And it doesn't matter
the order in which the two numbers come in.
So if I swap this around and if I had the
2 coming in here and a 1 coming in
here, it doesn't make any difference. The
smallest one is going to pop out the
bottom, and the biggest one is going to
pop out the right-hand side. So the game here
is we've got this basic building block
and we want to kind of plug these
together, just with pictures, and see
how you can build a little sorting program
The trick is that you just build a little
triangle of these boxes. So let's
put a bunch of these things together.
There's a little triangle of these boxes
and we're going to just wire them
together in a very straightforward way
We'll just draw the obvious little links
between them. And each of these boxes
just sorts two numbers, like we saw a few
moments ago. So let's take our little
example and just push it through this
little sorting network and actually
see what happens.  So I think the
numbers we had were 5, 2, 3, 1
and 4. So, out the bottom, we hope to get
12345. So let's see what happens.
So we're going to treat the first column
first of all and we'll see what happens.
So it's really simple. So, you've got the
2 and the 5 coming into the first box.
So the smallest number pops out the bottom.
So that's the 2, and the biggest
number comes out the right-hand side - so
that's the 5. And then we do the same with
the second box in the column. So we've
got 2 coming in, and a 3 coming in, so
the smallest number pops out the bottom.
And the biggest number comes out
the right-hand side. And we just do the same
again. Then we got a 1 and a 2 - so the 1
comes out the bottom, and the 2 comes out
the right-hand side. And then we've got 4
and a 1 - the 1 pops out the bottom and
the 4 comes out the right-hand side.
So what you see is that the smallest
number, which in this case is 1, has
kind of rippled its way down to the
bottom. So what's happened is this first
column has selected the smallest number.
And it's quite easy to see that that's
the case, because the top box selects the
smallest from the two numbers it's given,
and then the second box selects the
smallest numbers from the two numbers
it's given, and so on and so on.  So kind
of - the smallest number is going to
ripple its way down to the bottom - so
selecting the smallest one. Then we do
the same with the remaining columns, and
we won't be surprised with what happens.
So we've got a 3 coming in and a 5
coming in. So the 3 will pop out and
the 5 will pop out here. Then we got a 2
and the 3, so the 2 is smaller so it pops out.
And the 3 comes out here. And then we got 2 and
a 4, and the 2 is the smallest. And then
the 4 pops out the other side. You see
what's happened again: from the remaining
numbers 5, 3, 2 and 4, the second column
has selected the smallest one. And then, if
we just complete this, it's obvious what's
going to happen. We get a 3 here and a 5
here. 3,4,4,5. So what you see is that
our little sorting grid has taken five
numbers, in a mixed-up order, and just by
pushing them through, one column at a
time, we've ended up with the numbers in
the correct order. And this is known as
Selection Sort, because each column just
selects the smallest number from what is left.
OK? So nice and easy. You don't need to know
anything about computer science, anything
about algorithms, anyone can understand
what's going on with selection sort here.
But, you can actually view this picture
in another way. So let me re-draw the same
picture. So I just wire it up, in exactly
the same way as before. And we'll push
exactly the same five numbers through. So
we started off with a 5,2,3,1 and a 4.
So, what we did last time is we treated it
in terms of the columns. But actually you
can do exactly the same thing in terms
of the rows. So we'll do one row at a
time, and actually see what happens.  So,
if we consider the first row, it's the
same as before. We get the 2 and the
5 coming in. And the 2 pops out here,
and 5 pops out on the right-hand side,
because the 2 is the smallest one.
So we'll do the second row. So what happens?
So, we've got a 2 and a 3 coming in.
So the 2 is the smallest; it'll come out the
bottom. And 3 is the biggest so it comes
out on the right-hand side. And then we
go over to this box in the row. We've got
a 3 and a 5. So, the 3 comes out the
bottom, and the 5 comes out the
right-hand side. So what's
actually happened is the
second row has taken the 2 and the 5,
which are already in the right
order, because the first box did that
for us.  And it's taken the 3 and it's
put 3 into the correct place. So maybe
if I use a different colour here,
you can see this. So I've got
a 2 and a 5 here.  And then
I've got a 3 coming in on the
left-hand side. And what the second row
does, is it puts the 3 into the right place.
So, out the bottom, you get 2, 3 and 5.
So what the second row has done is
inserted this number into the right
place. And let's see what happens with
the next row. So then we've got a 1 and a 2
coming in. So the 1 comes out the bottom,
because it's the smallest. And then the
2 comes out here. And we've got a 2 and a 3
Se we get the 2 and the 3. And then we've got
a 3 and a 5. And the 3 is the smallest, so
it comes out here. What you see is exactly
the same thing has happened again. We
had a 1 here and then we had 2, 3
and 5, which has already being sorted
by the grid above us. And then this row
here is just going to put
the 1 into the right place.
What's popped out the bottom of this grid
is 1, 2, 3 and 5. So we just complete
the picture. We'll get the expected results.
So we've got a 1 and a 4. So, the 1 is the
smallest so it pops out the bottom. And the
4 goes around here. And we've got a 2 and
a 4. So the 2 pops out and the 4.  And the
3 and the 4. So the 3 is smallest and then
we get the 4 and the 5. This sorting
method, when you think about the
rows rather than the columns, is called
Insertion Sort. And it's called
insertion sort because each of these
rows just inserts a number into the
correct position in a sorted sequence. So,
for example, if we look at the bottom row
here, the input on the top is a
sorted sequence - 1, 2, 3 and 5 -
those are in the right order. And all the
bottom row is doing, is putting this 4
into the correct position so that we
get 1, 2, 3, 4 and 5.
Previously, we had exactly the same picture,
and we said that's selection sort,
if you view it in terms of the columns. And
if you take the same picture now, and
view it in terms of the rows, this way
around, then we get insertion sort. So, for
me this is a bit of magic. I've been in
computer science for a long, long time.
I was thinking about how to teach sorting
algorithms to my students a few years ago,
and came up with this pictorial idea, and
I didn't realize until then that
insertion sort and selection sort are
exactly the same thing. But you only see
this if you look at it in the
right way using the pictures.
>> Sean: Basically it all comes down to perspective, right?
>> Graham: Yes, exactly, it's ...
if you look at stuff in the right way
then you can see things that you
couldn't see before. So, if
you write programs to do
insertion sort or selection sort, the
kind of structure here, which is the same,
is being kind of hidden from you.
But if you just draw some simple
pictures and forget all your fancy
computing, then you end up with an
observation which is quite interesting.
>> Sean: Have you come across anything else that
that is kind of similar? Have you gone
through other sort of algorithms and
thought about them this way?
>> Graham: Yes a colleague of mine from Oxford a
few years ago, I was showing him this to
him. And he said: "Oh! we can write a paper
about this!" So we tried to look at, like,
Quicksort and Merge Sort, and see if they
had the same kind of duality. But it
didn't quite work out at the time. And we
kind of gave up writing the paper about
it. But, I think this is just a simple
observation in its own right here.